have you heard the phrase change is the
only constant in life well that may be
accurate for most things you don't want
it to be true for your infrastructure
let's take a look at how critter
Junction learned the hard way about
adopting immutable infrastructure
[Music]
mutable means capable of change in this
case we're talking about the idea of
cloud resources that are made to never
have manual changes for our friends at
critter Junction they started with
virtual machines that hosted their web
servers their VMs were originally
designed to be mutable because of the
short-term flexibility it gave them each
VM could more precisely fit the apps
that ran on it and it was easy to run
custom updates for each machine the team
often became attached to individual
machines which was occasionally useful
if they needed to fix specific problems
quickly for example they ran a VM with
nginx in version one of their web server
with data written locally when they
wanted to switch to Apache it was easy
for them to perform an upgrade on the
server directly and run version 2 on the
surface this seems great they were using
an existing server and didn't have to
worry about moving the data around other
machines or creating a new machine but
in the real world things can go wrong
the Apache upgrade could have failed for
a number of reasons like networking
issues in their case some of the servers
updated quickly while others got hung up
on installations they were left with
some servers running version 2
successfully
some that upgraded the apps but couldn't
run it and some servers that were still
running version ones many of their VMs
were failing in slightly different ways
and they were now facing complexity with
user traffic being routed to different
running versions of their web server an
inability to roll back to a previous
version and undocumented update statuses
making it impossible to track versions
instead of changing each of their
existing VMs they should have changed
their environment to be immutable once a
vm is deployed it can't be modified no
updates no matches no configuration
changes if you want to change
application code or apply a patch you
instead would build a new image and
deploy it as a replacement because new
environments can be spawned in the cloud
in a matter of minutes
immutable infrastructure is easy to
architect and deploy after some long
hours restoring version 1 of their
application here's how credit Junction
handled their next appointment
instead of making changes in place to
each machine they created a brand new VM
image with Apache and version 2 of their
app and move to any locally written data
to an attached persistent disk after
some testing to make sure the new image
was working they spun up multiple
servers using the new image now they
could safely switch traffic to their new
VMs and shut down the instances running
version ones on Google's files it looked
like this for their team they use cloud
build to set up continuous integration
with their repository automating billing
and testing vm's were specified using
image families so they could have
multiple versions of their images and
deprecated the newest versions if they
needed to roll back and they specified
all of their resources using cloud
deployment manager in order to
automatically provision it this is the
same pattern as working with containers
create a complete runtime environment
and deliver that as an image with
containers the runtime environment is a
program and the files it needs to run
with immutable infrastructure you're
delivering a full operating system
configured as needed along with the
program and their files in both cases
you continuously deliver versioned
images creating a mutable infrastructure
gave critter Junction protection from
configuration drift since they now know
the exact state of their machines and
can avoid any unexpected surprises in
addition they can now easily track
versions rollback releases and have a
more consistent testing process
thanks to the documented differences
between their environments immutable
infrastructure might sound at odds with
agile architecture but in reality it
gives you a chilla T because you know
the specifics and code status for every
resource in your environment stay tuned
to find out what's in store for critter
Junction and remember always be
architecting
[Music]